الخوف وانهزاميه قد يتسللان كما العدو الى
نفوس المقاتلين خوف ممزوج برؤى نهاري عن
اهوال ما يرونه في الحرب القوات
الاوكرانيه تحاول تقديم الدعم المناسب
لهؤلاء الجنود عبر توفير مسمته المظله
الروحيه لقوات الخطوط الاماميه وفق صحيفه
جيلجراف ضباط اوكرانيون اكدوا ان المظله
الاساسيه التي تحمي بلادهم هي القوات
المسلحه لكن هؤلاء بدورهم بحاجه للحمايه
النفسيه والمعنويه عشره عسكريين اوكرانيين
تدربوا لاسبوعين على يد الجيش البريطاني
في معسكر بالقرب من لتقديم الدعم المناسب
للجنود المشاركين تاء المشاركون تعلموا
كيفيه تقديم الرعايه والدعم النفسي
والتوجيه المعنوي للجنود في ساحه المعركه
الجيش الاوكراني يضم بالفعل 160 شخصا لهذه
المهمه انضموا الى هيكل القياده العسكريه
منذ ابريل الماضي فهؤلاء ياتون من اقسام
مختلفه مثل البحريه والمشاه والقوات
الخاصه والقسم الطبي ايضا واجتازوا اسابيع
من التدريب في بريطانيا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات